from the studio that promise not to make
sequels just to make sequels comes a
sequel that was made for one very clear
reason printing money finding dory
Hollywood's got a fever and not even
Pixar is immune so if you love secondary
comic relief characters getting their
own movies get ready cuz Disney's gonna
make you choke on him
you remember dory right she's back in a
story that answers all the questions you
never really had about her like who
wrote that just keep swimming song just
keep swimming just keep swimming it's
trending swimming swimming
how did Doyler to speak whale you know
me of course we talked through the pipes
when we were little we were pen pals and
how does your short-term memory-loss
work because forgetting your parents
exists isn't exactly a short-term memory
it's more of an excuse to create a
secret oh I see what you did there in
this kid's movie it takes a clear-eyed
look at mental disabilities I'm sorry
did I forget again and how funny it is
Becky's eating a cup Wow but Dory isn't
the only fish in the sea your favourites
are all back and they're not sure why
they're here either no we've got our
ocean Travis join them as a whole
schools worth of wacky new creatures to
help Dory on her journey and conduct a
marketing test to see who should get
their own spin-off like Hank the escape
artist that was clearly created after an
octopus escapes video went viral a whale
shark whose character is bumps into
things ah this guy that makes annoying
noises to make your kids laugh
and Sigourney Weaver hello I'm Sigourney
Weaver watch as they all unite in an
action-packed finale we're a bunch of
fish staged a jailbreak from a rehab
center where an octopus by Jackson truck
then drives it back to the ocean
somehow listen it's bright and loud your
kids are gonna love it
the inside out seems like so long ago
now so just keep swimming with this
unnecessary sequel that's all about
memory yeah it's still completely
forgettable as Pixar rolls out its cold
calculating formula for warmth and hard
one more time featuring and adorable
little baby voice protagonist hey enjoy
a grizzled but lovable jerk another
story about getting separated from your
loved ones I've lost my family can you
help me strategically-placed cute stuff
the OL your parents are dead fake out
Tory they're gone and a touching ending
where discovers that she was never truly
forgotten because her parents kept hope
alive
I left her favorite shelves behind as a
guide to lead her back home where she
was hooked have you pigs are either your
B material begs me cry starring Dorothy
ignore ax
finding Hank coming summer 2022 Annoying
Orange emo black fish Professor X
jumping the shark Becky with a good
stare conveniently placed water and
reverse anagen I'd like to I don't like
sand seeing this Christmas course rough
and irritating and it gets everywhere
finding money if you thought this was
bad just wait until they announce the
bing-bong prequel oh yeah we're calling
it he proved that love conquers all what
a bunch of bull
they call you the Boy Who Lived because
the most interesting thing about you is
that you are technically alive when you
look like Mumford if he ate all his sons
do you remember when you looked into my
mind decades of me wanking it to your
mum you know the differences between me
and you Severus one of us knows what
it's like to slide out of Lily Potter's
book screen junkies presents the roast
of Harry Potter exclusively on screen
junkies plus watch now hey screen
junkies click the box on the left to
watch the roast of Harry Potter if you
register now with Facebook you can watch
five screen junkies plus videos for free
or click the Box on the right and watch
our honest trailer for finding nemo now
it's time for me to find some comments
Michael Bay is one of the most
hardworking and creative directors in
film history and it's better than Steven
Spielberg what it do baby boo chuckle
Nuggets my face smells like a
marshmallow Dormammu I've come to
bargain for mission report December 16
1991 I need to tape the tape so I can
have tapes tapes take with tapes taped